>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS BECAUSE
THIS WAS A SHOCK.
I WAS ASKING WERE PEOPLE
EXPECTING THIS AT ALL?
NO.
SO DR. TARA NARULA IS WITH US.
THEY SAY IT'S AN APPARENT
CARDIAC ARREST SHE DIED AFTER
BEING RUSHED TO THE HOSPITAL
AFTER THE APPARENT CARDIAC
ARREST.
SHE WAS SO YOUNG.
WHAT WOULD LEAD TO?
>> WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
CARDIAC ARREST A LOT LATELY WITH
HAMLIN IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT MEANS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK IT'S A
HEART TAEK BUT A CARDIAC ARREST
IS A PRIMARY ELECTRICAL PROBLEM
WITH THE HEART, IT'S NOT BEATING
EFFECTIVELY OR APPROPRIATELY.
AND YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO PUMP
BLOOD OUT TO THE REST OF THE
BODY TO THE BRAIN, THE OTHER
ORGANS AND QUICKLY, WITHIN
MINUTES YOU CAN HAVE DEATH
RESULT IF YOU'RE NOT TREATED
WITH THINGS LIKE CPR OR
POTENTIALLY DEFIBRILLATION.
WE TALKED ABOUT 350,000 CARDIAC
DEATHS A YEAR OUTSIDE OF THE
HOSPITAL.
BUT THIS REALLY IS, YOU KNOW,
IT'S ANOTHER SAD, YOU KNOW,
TRAGIC EVENT AND UNFORTUNATELY
50% OF THE TIME, THE FIRST
MANIFESTATION OF HEART DISEASE
IS SUDDEN CARDIAC ARREST.
SO PEOPLE MAY NOT KNOW THEY HAD
RISK FACTORS.
>> SHE HAD BEEN GETTING MEDICAL
ATTENTION HER FAMILY SAID.
DO WE KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT -- THE
FACT THAT SHE WAS ON THE RED
CARPET TWO DAYS BEFORE THIS
HAPPENED WOULD SHOCK PEOPLE.
>> THAT'S HOW CARDIAC ARREST AND
DISEASE WORKS SOMETIMES.
PEOPLE CAN LOOK FINE UNTIL THEY
HAVE A STROKE, HEART ATTACK,
CARDIAC ARREST.
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT CARDIAC
ARREST IS 70% IS DUE TO
UNDERLYING STRUCTURAL HEART
DISEASE.
MOST OF THE TIME IT'S CORONARY
HEART DISEASE BUT MANY TIMES IT
CAN BE A PROBLEM WITH THE HEART
MUSCLE WHERE THE HEART MUSCLE IS
SCARRED OR THERE'S FAILURE OF
THE HEART MUSCLE BUT SOMETIMES,
IN ABOUT 10% OF THE CASES IT CAN
BE A PRIMARY GENETIC ELECTRICAL
PROBLEM.
AND THERE'S THINGS LIKE
RECREATIONAL DRUG USE.
SO THERE'S A HOST OF REASONS ONE
MIGHT HAVE A CARDIAC ARREST.
ONE IS TO LOOK FOR THE RISK
FACTORS AND TRY TO SCREEN AND
TREAT THOSE, THE SAME FOR
CARDIAC ARREST ARE THE SAME WE
TALK ABOUT FOR HEART ATTACK,
HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE, DIABETES,
SMOKING, OBESITY.
>> FILM AND ENTERTAINMENT
JOURNALIST JOINS ME NOW FROM
LOS ANGELES.
ANDREW, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
GIVEN THAT LISA MARIE'S FATHER
WAS ONE OF THE MOST, IF NOT THE
MOST ICONIC POSITION OF
ALL-TIME.
SHE DID CHART HER OWN COURSE.
SHE BECAME A MUSICIAN, AND THIS
CANNOT BE EASY BECAUSE THIS
GIGANTIC LECTURES LOOMING OVER.
>> PAPA BIG SHOES TO FILL.
AND TALK ABOUT LEGACY.
I THINK LISA MARIE DID SO TO
KEEP HER FATHER'S MEMORY ALIVE.
AS THE KEEP AND MAKE HIM AN
ICON.
SHE --
IN 2005.
AND RIGHT UP TO THE END.
SHE WAS CELEBRATING THE LIFE OF
HER FATHER, LAST SUNDAY, AND
WITH THAT BEEN AS DOES HIS
BIRTHDAY.
SHOULDN'T GRACELAND SURROUNDED
BY ADORING FANS, ON TUESDAY AS
AROUND THE GOLDEN GLOBE AWARDS.
OR SHE WAS CELEBRATING THE
MOVIE ELVIS.
AND THOSE THUS WHO LOVE THE
FAMILY --
IN THE FINAL DAYS.
CELEBRATING HER DAD, A LEGACY,
AND WHAT THE SADDEST PARTS OF
THE STORY THAT HER MOTHER HAD
TO ANNOUNCE THE DAUGHTERS THAT.
SO IT'S PRISCILLA THE CUSTODIAN
OF THE BRAND AS IT WERE IN
KEEPING ELVIS'S MEMORY ALIVE.
>> THE PUBLIC CUSTODIAN OF THE
BRAND, YES, CERTAINLY.
YOU'VE BEEN THOUGH THE RIGHTS
AND IMAGES.
HAVE BEEN SOLD OFF YEARS AGO.
BUT PRISCILLA I'VE MET SEVERAL
TIMES AND SHE'S DONE A
WONDERFUL JOB THIS.
NO MOTHER SHOULD GO THROUGH
THIS.
I MEAN PRAYERS AND TALK WITH
AROUND THE WORLD.
WHEN THE NICEST PEOPLE I WOULD
SAY AND MY HEART BREAKS FOR
HER.
BUT >> OBVIOUSLY HER FAMILY,
AND HOLLYWOOD IN THE INDUSTRY
ARE REELING, BECAUSE THEIR
DEPTH HAD COME AT A SHOCK.
WHAT TRIBUTES ARE POURING IN.
>> AMONG THE TRIBUTES, ONE FROM
A THIRD HAS BEEN.
AFTER NICHOLAS CAGE.
AND I THINK HE GOT IT RIGHT
WHEN HE SAID THAT LISA MARIE
SHE LIT UP EVERY ROOM.
SHE WALKED INTO.
SHE REALLY DID.
JOHN TRAVOLTA AMONG OTHER STARS
PAIN TRIBUTE.
HERE IN HOLLYWOOD IT HITS US.
WITH SO MUCH SURPRISE.
NOT LEAST BECAUSE SO MANY OF US
SAW HER JUST THIS WEEK AT THE
GOLDEN GLOBE AWARDS.
AND THAT MOVIE, ELVIS, IT'S
JUST FANTASTIC.
AND SHE WAS SO PLEASE SEE
AUSTIN BUTLER WHEN THE GOLDEN
GLOBE FOR BEST ACTOR.
BECAUSE SHE WAS SAYING IT TOOK
HER FIVE DAYS TO GET OVERSEEING
THE FILM.
EVEN THOUGH SHE'S SEEN EVERY
HEALTH IS A PERSONALITY
VETERAN.
SHE SAID THAT NOBODY I'VE GOT A
FATHER SPIRIT, PRESENTS, AND
VOICE, QUITE HIS RIGHT AS
ALLISON BUTLER DID.
I WAS SO PROUD AND SO HAPPY TO
BE A DECIDE REPRESENTED THAT
MOVIE I'VE BEEN.
AND IT REALLY KEEPS ELVIS'S
MEMORY ALIVE.
JUST DAYS LATER WE HAVE MORE
HEARTBREAKING TRAGEDY FROM THIS
ICONIC FAMILY.
>> PEOPLE THAT FOLLOW THE STORY
WILL BE AWARE OF HER SON
COMMITTING SUICIDE.
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT SHE DID
SPEAK ABOUT.
TELL US ABOUT YOUR CHILDREN AND
HOW SHE SURVIVED BY.
WHO YOUR FREIGHTERS AND BENJAMI,
WHO TOOK HIS OWN LIFE AT AGE 27,
AND 2020.
ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATING.
HOW DOES ANY MOTHER GET OVER
THAT?
SHOWS US THREE DAUGHTERS WHO
SHE DOTED ON.
INCLUDING RILEY KIIR, A VERY
MUCH A RISING STAR ACTRESS.
AND I REFLECT THAT SO MANY OF
THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE BORN TO
FAME, WEALTH, AND PRIVILEGE.
LIFE DOESN'T ALWAYS TURN OUT TO
BE SUNSHINE AND RAINBOWS.
SUCH AS THE CASE WITH THE
SUMMARY.
HALEP HAD THEIR FAIR SHARE OF
HEARTBREAK AS WELL.
FOR DIVORCES, BUT HER FANS
ALWAYS SUSTAINED HER.
HER FAMILY SUSTAINED HER.
SHE LOVED HER KIDS.
SHE WAS A GREAT PERSON.
AND THIS IS A DEVASTATING LOSS.
>> SANDRA THEY SAID YOU'VE SEEN
AT THE GOLDEN GLOBES RECENTLY
SHE WAS A LOVELY PERSON.
ARE THERE ANY STORIES ABOUT HER
THAT YOU THINK TYPIFY WHO SHE
WAS.
I REMEMBER MENTIONING THE FIRST
TIME I EVER MET OR SAYING THAT
I'VE BEEN TO GRACELAND.
AND I ACTUALLY STAYED AT THE
HEARTBREAK HOTEL.
WHICH IS ACTUALLY DOWN AT THE
END OF --
IT IS NOT THERE ANYMORE.
BUT SARAH MEMBER LAUGHING WITH
HER ABOUT HOW BIZARRE THIS WAS
TO BE WHERE THIS HAD THEIR HAS
INSPIRED THIS ACTUAL TELL, AND
THE SPECIAL PLACE.
AND I TOLD HER EVEN THOUGH I
WAS NEVER PLAYED IN ENGLAND,
HOW MUCH HE WAS LOVED THERE.
AND SHE KNEW WHAT SHE'S HEARD
ALL THE STORIES BEFORE.
AND SO, AS A MOTHER, PRISCILLA.
BUT IT IS GREAT TO THEN FORCE
ALWAYS --
MUCH OUR FAMILY HAS LOVED.
AND I THANK THE FAMILY SORT OF
DEALS WITH THIS HAVE ANY
COMPANY THOUGH.
SHE UNDRESSES FAMILY ARE VERY
PRESENT AROUND THE WORLD
BELONGED PUT BROKEN HEARTS
TODAY.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
INSIGHT ON THIS.